foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar titled RT
lamp best practices and tips to
accelerate detection of viral pathogens
including SARS cov2
this webinar is a part of the 10th
Annual genetics virtual week
I am Marie Stone of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and sponsored by
Thermo Fisher Scientific
for more information about Thermo Fisher
Scientific go to thermofisher.com
now let's get started before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you
first to participate by communicating
with other attendees using our new live
chat feature during the presentation you
can find the live chat located at the
right of your screen
you can also participate by submitting
as many questions as you like during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
submit in addition to asking questions
we encourage you to participate in three
poll questions in the middle of the
speaker's presentation click on your
answer when the poll questions are
displayed if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
help desk button located at the bottom
of your screen within the navigation bar
or from the lobby
I now present today's speakers ingrida
vandelay PhD r d manager for molecular
and synthetic biology Thermo Fisher
Scientific
and Leanne burrow PhD r d scientist
molecular biology Thermo Fisher
Scientific
for a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
left of your screen Dr vandelay and Dr
burrow you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone so my name is ingrida and
I'd like to start by welcoming everyone
again to this webinar focused on RT ramp
today we will start with a brief
technical introduction to rtlam as a
method and then share advice on how to
set up your workspace when working with
this highly sensitive technique we would
also cover run primer design
recommendations and share a simple
practical example of primer validation
process
we will also demonstrate how to generate
a synthetic RNA control which could be
used to validate your reverse
transcription lamp results
and finally we'll finish by sharing
practical rtlam solutions for South
School virtue research and surveillance
lamp stands for loop-mediated isothermal
amplification it is a fast simple and
specific DNA amplification technique
under isothermal conditions DNA
polymerase used in love has a strong
strand displacement activity meaning
that amplification of DNA can occur at a
single temperature because there is no
need for a denaturation step to separate
DNA strands when RNA is used as a
template a reverse transcriptase can be
incorporated into the reaction to
convert RNA into copy DNA
briefly lamp uses four to six primers as
demonstrated on the right amplification
is initiated by a strand invasion of an
inner primer and subsequent synthesis of
an inner sequence
the inner Primal also contains a
complementary sequence and following
annealing of an outer primer which
displaces the first product the
complementary sequence allows the
formation of a self-hybridizing loop at
the end and this form dumbbell structure
then serves as a seed for subsequent
exponential lamp amplification it has
multiple sites now for amplification
initiation
the end products are very long which are
also connected by single standard Loop
regions into long concateners or often
also called
cauliflower-like structures
the main lamp advantages are related to
Simplicity and flexibility since it is
an isothermal Technique No thermal
cycler is required and only a hidden
block is sufficient it offers the fast
turnaround time from 15 to 30 minutes or
even shorter sometimes and also multiple
detection solutions from real-time
analysis to endpoint detection
it is a simple workflow with only a few
steps and as mentioned if irony is the
target is simply incorporating reverse
transcriptase is enough and all these
features make lamp compatible for use
and low resource or in-field settings
when choosing to use lamp it's really
important to pay attention for a proper
primer design in order to control for a
false positive signal and hopefully
today we'll provide you good
recommendations and insight on how to do
that
I'd like to provide some recommendations
to help prepare your workspace in order
to avoid false positive signals as
mentioned before and when preparing ball
clamp experiments or simply handling a
large number of samples during your
asset development there's always a risk
of workspace contamination and resulting
false positive signal so General
guidelines for working in the lab apply
is is wearing a clean laboratory code or
gloves while performing experiments
washing your hands prior to working in
the lab and changing lives frequently
during the experiment especially after
cleaning your workspace such as laminar
full hood or prior to adding your no
template controls or negative control
samples always follow the recommended
cleaning instructions prior until after
each experiment as provided in the
protocol or a user guide and just
generally follow good laboratory
practice guidelines
who had been looking at lamp related
guidelines I'd like to specifically
highlight that using separate workspace
areas for RT lamp reaction preparation
and amplification from RT lamp amplicon
analysis by endpoint detection when
post-reaction tube opening is required
is specifically important to avoid a
false positive signal discard use the
agents if you suspect a carryover
contamination and replace with fresh
ones allocate your reagents into working
stock volumes such as salad cutting
primers or your RNA DNA targets or
internal controls is good practice and
always use filtered Piper tips and of
course change your Piper tips between
your Tactical replicates
um so if you're preparing lamp reaction
to detect a DNA Target we recommend to
clean your lab space
um within vitrogen DNA zap crdna
degradation solution to remove any
potential
um contamination applicants from your
surroundings and then clean your
workspace with the DNA sinus free
distilled water to remove residual
solution and the contaminated workspace
with a 70 ethanol solution however if
your target is an RNA a sample then also
clean with your investigen rna's
apparents the contamination solution to
remove any potential adenases that could
degrade your RNA Target and then remove
the residual solution with the 70
ethanol solution
covered the most important
recommendation is really to not open
tubes or Wells after ramp amplification
and the reaction setup space to prevent
amplicons spreading on the workspaces
and contaminating causing a false
positive signal in your new reactions
also seal your node template control
tubes or Wells prior to adding a Target
RNA or DNA
and if contamination is observed also
consider using a different timer system
targeting potentially another genome
region as well prepare negative controls
in a separate area to avoid a false
positive signal and also multiple
technical replicates are always
recommended for your samples and for
your controls to properly validate your
reaction outcome
and here's a simple example of a
workspace when multiple reactions are
being set up so here we're looking at
the laminal flow Hood which contains
cool racks to store your reagents as
well as your reaction mix if there is
temperature sensitive and
gloves are one and filter tips are used
during the preparation of multiple
technical replicas
contamination can be recognized easily
when real-time detection method is
selected to either screen multiple timer
sets or to observe your reaction
kinetics and in such case a melt curve
profile can be examined and usually a
specific amplification
produces a sharp narrow Peak and here
it's highlighted in red and to also
demonstrate that your technical
replicates overlay nicely each other
showing a specific amplical however
non-specific amplification can be
identified by observing double Peaks or
wide shoulders or even a shift in the
Melt temperature by more than one degree
if endpoint detection is chosen please
have multiple negative controls as
indicated here in the orange color tubes
and observing a single color change
which would indicate a false positive
separating it from the rest of your
technical replicates gives us an idea
that this is potentially a
cross-contaminated reaction Max
um just checking it on an agarose
electrophoresis gel you can observe a
blur pattern in the background which
indicates a false positive potentially
resulting from a carryover contamination
and the reaction mix
as mentioned lime primers are crucial
for successful lamp amplification and
here are some guidelines on how to
successfully design primers lamp employs
four to six primers binding six distant
regions of the target DNA and even
though reaction can be set up using four
primers so inner and outer primers
addition of the two Loop timers
significantly speeds up amplification
inner primers are here conforming
primers that hybridize to the
complementary and reverse complementary
Target sequences which forms the
dumbbell-like structure and leads to the
auto cycling lamp
the target sequence is also important
and successful amp acid design and if
faced with high sequence radiation from
strain to strain and aiming to detect
multiple streams select conserved
regions across chains and variants to
avoid false narratives results or also
avoid conserved genes from closely
related organisms to avoid a false
positive result and plus can be used to
check for non-specific targets
select homologous regions across trains
to detect multiple related strains and
if aiming to detect multiple strains you
can also use multiple primer sets or
degenerate primers
key considerations for a successful
timer design are very similar to General
PCR primer rules so GC contact needs to
be monitored and limited as well as the
melting temperature of the primers is
important and lump is usually carried
out at 65 degrees so that should also be
the melting temperature
with your primary design it is important
that primers do not form secondary
structures especially for the inner
primer which is longer and forms the
tumble structure and to prevent the
formation of primer dimers it is also
important to ensure that the three ends
are not complementary
a word runs of three or more of one base
or the nucleotide repeats and if
restriction enzyme sites exist in the
Target sequence outside the primary
regions they can be used to confirm the
Amplified product in such case you would
see a single band on the gel instead of
a signature lamp a ladder-like pattern
check distances between Target regions
as provided here and also monitor here
with melting temperature
here I'd like to present an online tool
for non-primal design which is the most
popular free tool to design primer since
it's cited in the majority of literature
it's called primer Explorer it has been
developed by Lands inventors and the
link is provided here on the slide it
has a very descriptive informative user
guide and manual which really provides a
lot of useful information how to design
successful primer sets it has some
limitations it's limited by 2000 base
per Target sequence it supports only
atcg characters and doesn't handle
multi-sequence alignment representation
with generate nucleotides which is often
a problem when trying to design book
primers so we suggest not to use the
generated nucleotypes
um it's limited to a single execution
process and the output is in the HTML
format but despite this it's an
excellent tool
um it's used very frequently and cited
the literature which really indicates
that the primers work well and as
mentioned it has a very descriptive user
guide for more information
so now I'd like to present a very
simplified primer validation process
example and here we're looking at the
target of synthetic measles are the name
and primers here are either custom
designed using the tool that I just
presented or taken from published
literature and the materials for lamp
were in vitrogen superscripts for rt1
master mix in this region site online
green fluorescent nucleic acid stain for
real-time detection to observe reaction
kinetics and of course hboc purified
primers with the concentrations
described at the bottom left corner said
the daughter looking at primers from
Publications and at the bottom custom
designed and what we are looking at in
the lamp kinetic profile is fast
reaction speed we want to have a fast
lamp
outcome we want to see good
reproducibility between technical
replicates so they should overlay each
other despite the animated copy input
and we want to have a wide long
specificity window between specific
amplification and non-specific
amplification start which is indicated
by Green curves so if looking at
publication primers at the left we have
a speed of just 10 minutes technical
replicates are better reproducible
specificity Windows about 35 minutes
allowing for a fast and specific
reaction and then on the right we have
non-specific amplification overlaying
your specific curves
reproducibility is not great and
Technical replicates are spread out and
we would have difficulties and
separating a false positive signal from
a specific amplification here at the
bottom Custom Design primers are
compared and even though they are custom
designed they do not show equal
performance so on the right design a
even though it hasn't shown on specific
signal that a predictability is poor
variability is high technical replicates
are spread out from 10 to 20 minutes
while on the left we have a speed of
just five minutes technical replicates
overly each other in specificative
window is the longest about 40 minutes
so both publication a primer set and
Custom Design B show Goods performance
as we would like to have and here
um we selected simply Custom Design B
because of the speed
um it's a faster speed but both show a
good performance who could be used and
hopefully this example provides you
information on what to look for when
examining a lamb kinetic profile
and finally I'd like to present on how
to design a positive control for your
RTO map outcome validation
so using positive and negative controls
is recommended to validate artery lamp
reaction outcome and when considering
your negative controls there are several
several options so a node template
control where a reaction mix with water
instead of a Target can be used a
negative clinical sample when we know
that a Target is not present in the
sample a sample with another qualitative
agent so for instance if aiming to
detect measles influenza could be used
to make sure that your primers do not
bind non-specifically to another costed
agent or Universal human RNA sample of
human clinical samples are being used
there is a likelihood of background
ionies being present and this is also a
good negative control and for positive
controls they can be either made in
house or purchased commercially
and if choosing to make your RNA control
in-house there are two possible
workflows and the most
frequently used is cloning into
expression plasm at the Target DNA and
then
linearizing purification description
steps can take several days so today I'd
like to present an alternative workflow
which only takes a few hours and uses
GNR strings DNA fragments
so sympathizing at a knee using genot
strings DNA fragments and shorten your
workflow significantly and here we're
looking at three Gene strings that we
used
to produce our internal rnas
double standard DNA strings contain
these seven RNA polymerase promoter
upstream and also had restriction size
sites added on both ends just in case
Downstream cloning application is
planned but they are optional and
absolutely not required and such Gene
strings can be used for individual
transcription reactions without the need
for cloning directly into the
transcription reaction which shortens
your workflows significantly chain
strings are supplied highly pure which
again helps to ensure your
transcriptional yields are great which
is important and simplified workflow to
generate high quality yields of
synthetic RNA fragments within only a
few hours is presented so instead of
this you can have your RNA much quicker
and here are steps so reaction setup is
about 15 minutes only and add any
synthesis using thermoscientific
transcript 87 high yield transcription
kit is about two hours and then
purification using the investigen mega
clear transcription cleanup kit is about
20 minutes and and on the right you can
see the amount of synthetic RNA that was
generated from just these three simple
steps
at the bottom we have
electrotherograms of synthesized RNA
fragments we can see Sharp peaks of our
Target RNA of expected size with three
different strings that were used in our
reactions
and here positive controls velocity lamp
are validated so first transcribed RNA
was Quantified where real-time rtq PCR
here I'm only presenting
um genestring C and you can see the copy
number that was calculated from rtq PCR
results many copies were generated
directly from just one microgram of
custom DNA Gene strings and a real-time
multi-lamp using Saito 9 green
fluorescent nucleic acid stain
demonstrated that RNA transcribed from
genestring C demonstrated equal
performance to commercial control or
purified clinical RNA and the time to
result was just 5.8 minutes when
commercial control was just 5.2 and we
have two good examples of clinical
samples with high or low add a new copy
number and the reaction time was very
similar
so this is the first of our three poll
questions
what Target would you need to detect if
you would use lamp technology
RNA DNA or both
I'll give you some time to make your
selection again the poll question is
what Target would you need to detect if
you would use lamp technology
RNA DNA or both
our second poll question what sample
type would you prefer to use for lamp
purified RNA or DNA
Direct lysate
unpurified samples easy saliva or swabs
make your selection click on the answer
again the poll question is what sample
type would you prefer to use for lamp
purified RNA or DNA
Direct lysate
unpurified samples EG saliva or swabs
and you'll have about
five to eight more seconds to make your
selection
and then moving on to our final poll
question
what lamp endpoint analysis is
preferable for you
colorimetric
turbidity
gel electrophoresis
fluorescence
lateral flow
again to record your answer click on the
one that is
best describes what your needs are
question again what lamp endpoint
analysis is preferable for you
calorimetric turbidity gel
electrophoresis fluorescence lateral
flow
make sure to click on the answer to
record
your answer
and we'll now turn it back over to our
next speaker for their presentation
I'll pass to my colleague Leanne to
present RT lab solutions for star school
V2 research and surveillance
thank you ingrida and hello everyone my
name is Leanne and I'll be presenting
the last portion of our webinar we're
focused on RT lamp Solutions specific
for SARS cov2 research and surveillance
SARS cov2's emergence spread and health
outcomes have impacted all of our Lives
perhaps one of the most important
lessons we learned however is the need
for accurate sensitive and available
molecular testing solutions for
infectious disease displayed here is a
snapshot of the United States Centers
for Disease Control and prevention's
timeline of the appearance and response
for SARS Kobe 2. in February 2020 only
three months after the first mnemonic
cases were reported the U.S and many
other nations identified the immediate
need for widely available molecular
tests today Mass vaccination has been
possible in the Americas Europe
Australia and many parts of Asia however
molecular testing remains critical for
unvaccinated groups including within
emerging Nations for young children for
whom the vaccine is not available and
within vaccine hesitant populations
Furthermore with the evolution of viral
variants molecular testing provides us
with epidemiological data on the
incidence distribution and impact of
vaccination on SARS cov2 derived
pneumonia
let's discuss the SARS cov2 virus in
Greater detail
severe acute respiratory syndrome
coronavirus 2 or SARS cov2 is a positive
sense single-stranded RNA virus
virus attaches to host cells using its
eponymous Crown like Spike proteins in
the diagram on the left the viral RNA is
shown in red and these Spike proteins
are shown in Orange
SARS cov2 molecular tests detect either
this RNA or Spike protein
as far as Kobe 2 infections continue to
spread novel variants have evolved these
variants of interests have small RNA
changes in the S Gene resulting in amino
acid changes in the spike protein these
changes May either help the viral
variants exhibit better host cell
attachment increased transmission or
viral load or improve the ability of the
virus to evade the host antibodies
with so much research and development on
SARS Kobe 2 it can be a challenge to
understand and relate all the
information that's been given to us here
we're outlining two of the most common
attributes first SARS cov2 test types as
well as the required sample types
SARS cov2 is principally a lower
respiratory disease however viruses may
be detected in minimally invasive sample
types like saliva nasopharyngeal swabs
and nasal swabs Additionally the human
immune response to the virus may be
observed using a blood sample type
shown on the right there are three
common types of SARS cov2 testing
nucleic acid-based antigen-based and
antibody test
nucleic acid-base test detects SARS cov2
RNA this is colored in red these tests
may be called PCR or qpcr tests and are
very sensitive and specific most nucleic
acid testing requires trained scientists
and a centralized laboratory determine
if the virus is present therefore these
tests often take hours to days to
perform and may be expensive
alternatively antigen-based tests or
rapid tests detect SARS cov2 proteins
these tests may be performed at the
point of care without extensive training
or specialized instrumentation
these type of tasks can tell a patient
whether or not SARS cov2 is present at
very high levels only therefore this
fast inexpensive test will identify
those patients that are likely
contagious
finally antibody tests detect the human
immune response to SARS cov2 exposure
these tests can inform a patient on
whether they recently had or have an
infection and the results are typically
provided with a quick turnaround time
and little Financial investment
in addition to this common SARS cov2
test we just discussed RT lamp may be
used for SARS research and surveillance
on the left we're depicting SARS cov2
viral load variation where a person on
the extreme left in yellow only has a
low viral load this low viral load may
be detected with qpcr tests only because
these tests have high sensitivity
on the right the person in red has an
extremely high viral load this High
viral load may be detected by any test
including the antigen tests which have
the lowest sensitivity
RT lamp based tests for SARS cov2 are
uniquely positioned as they're nearly as
sensitive as the qpcr test and are
nearly as fast as the antigen tests the
application of RT lamp is so well suited
for SARS Kobe 2 that the landscape of
this approach has drastically shifted
over the last two years
as seen on the right of the side in 2019
only about two percent of RT lamp
Publications were focused on SARS cov2
however in 2020 this metric drastically
shifted with approximately 60 percent of
all lamp Publications focused on sarsko
V2 research available
Fisher Scientific is invested in
providing RT lamp-based solutions for
infectious disease detection including
SARS cov2 research and surveillance in
the last year and greatest team and my
team have been focused on two specific
offerings the first is the invitrogen
superscript 4 RT lamp Master mix this is
an optimized enzymatic Master mix
resulting in outstanding RT layout
performance a mastermix provides the
ultimate flexibility allowsing the user
to select their pathogen of Interest
their target and their readout method
the second solution is the invitrogen
colorimetric ready lamp kit this is an
off-the-shelf complete kit for SARS cov2
detection in saliva or NP or nasal swabs
two reaction controls and two workflows
optimized for sample types are included
as with the superscript 4 RT lamp Master
mix the color metric ready lamp is
intended for ruo only applications with
minimal cost or instruments Investments
required
okay now I'm going to focus on the SARS
cov2 research using just the complete
kit
color metric ready light kit provides
two workflows one for RNA samples and
one for crude samples in the case of RNA
sample type the user collects saliva
nasal or a nasopharyngeal swabs SARS
Kobe 2 RNA is isolated from these
samples and then finally the isolated
RNA is used in the color metric ready
lamp kit as sample input
here the user assembles an RT lamp
reaction incubasex 65 degrees for 30
minutes and then interprets whether the
saliva or swab sample type contains SARS
cov2 based on colorectric change
samples lacking SARS cov2 will remain
purple in color while SARS containing
while samples containing SARS cov2 will
turn from purple to blue color
for the crude sample types this exact
protocol is used with the RNA isolation
step emitted
SARS cov2 from these samples is
inactivated in laced and directly added
to the color metric readylamp assay
let's look at some of the SARS cov2
detection data with a color metric ready
lamp kit
for RNA samples these are shown on the
left the complete workflow including RNA
isolation was used 96 saliva and 96 MP
samples were processed where half of
each sample type contain the SARS cov2
virus
the RT lamp reactions containing 100
copies of SARS cov2 from both samples
all turned the initial from the initial
purple color to the positive blue color
demonstrating positive overall reaction
while all reactions lacking SARS cov2
remained purple in color
for the crude samples types that are
shown on the right the workflow emitting
RNA isolation was implemented in this
case all RT lab reactions containing 250
copies of SARS cov2 turned blue well
reactions lacking SARS cov2 Remain the
initial purple color
overall with both sample types Superior
performance in terms of RT lamp accuracy
and specificity are recorded
one critical question about the color
metric ready lamp kit is does the RT
lamp reaction detect SARS cov2 variants
SARS cov2 variants have a key RNA change
in the S Gene but don't have concomitant
changes in other regions of the genome
the color metric ready lamp primers
don't Target the S Gene and therefore
should capture all viral variants of
concern in fact when we investigated
more than 633 000 deposited SARS cov2
genomes more than 98 are perfectly
complementary to the kit primers
furthermore we purchased 15 available
SARS cov2 variants for all 15 the color
metric ready lamp kit detected the
presence of the virus at 50 copies per
RT lab reaction supporting that this kit
does detect SARS Kobe 2 variants
finally we demonstrate that the color
metric ready lamp kit is specific for
SARS cov2 and does not suffer from false
positives in the presence of other
respiratory pathogens
we tested isolated nucleic acid from 12
saliva donors containing either flu a
pooled respiratory panel SARS cov2 or no
pathogen the respiratory panels tested
herein are pooled aliquots of 8 to 10
causative agents of respiratory disease
as you can see only RT lamp reactions
that contained 100 copies of SARS cov2
turned from purple to Blue and thus are
called positive reactions while all
other RT lab reactions remained purple
in color and are negative
this data fully supports the specificity
of the color metric ready lamp kit for
detecting SARS cov2 and differentiating
between different types of respiratory
disease
we hope you now have a better
understanding of how rtla may accelerate
detection of viral pathogens including
sarasco V2 today we provided a
theoretical introduction to lamp
technology and practical information on
the rtlab workspaces primer design and
validation and synthesizing RNA controls
furthermore we described the Thermo
Fisher Scientific RT lamp solutions for
research and surveillance
thank you Dr vandelay then Dr burrow for
your time today and your important
research before we go I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
I'd also like to thank our sponsors
Thermo Fisher Scientific for sponsoring
today's webinar
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand for
two years until April 21st 2024.
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye